Hey, it's me.
And it's all about the data.
We are spending way too much time
wondering whether Taylor Swift
is going to appear on stage
in a cornfield in Dubuque
next to Joe Biden.
That is not what the Trump
campaign is
actually worried about, though
admittedly, that scene
would not be great for them. No.
What they're worried about
or should be worried about
is Taylor's data.
Couple of facts.
279 million.
That's the number of her followers
on Instagram.
4.35 million.
That's the number of tickets
sold for the era's tour.
$1 billion.
That's the tour's record
shattering revenue.
26.1 billion.
That's the number of Swift's
global streams on Spotify last year.
200 million.
That's how much tour merch has been sold.
So far.
Just how popular is she?
The only available
gray T-shirt sizes
remaining are in three XL and four XL.
I know. I checked.
I could go on and on and on,
but I don't need to.
Taylor knows.
Taylor knows
your social media interactions,
where you saw her on tour,
how much merch you bought from
her website.
She knows the size of your T-shirt,
the number of downloads you've made.
We're embarking on an election cycle
that will be a
the most expensive in history,
and b,
we'll see much of the money
spent on micro-targeting.
What's micro-targeting?
It's the use of online data to tailor,
pun intended, advertise
messages to individuals
based on the identification
of recipients,
personal vulnerabilities and interests
in order to target effectively.
Data is essential,
and Taylor's got lots and lots of it.
And on a demographic
that is exactly what the Biden team needs
the most.
Disproportionately female, young
and passionate
with truly the touch of a button.
Taylor Swift is uniquely situated
to use the data at her disposal
to impact the presidential race overall.
Most of Swift's social media
following
61.5% female on TikTok, specifically
the fan base is more female, 80.8%
and younger.
62% in the 18 to 24 age group,
according to polling by SRS.
As of October, that's
after the Kelsey Romance began.
A majority of US adults,
59%, identified as fans of Swift.
63% of women said so.
Her fans are evenly divided
5050 between Democrats
or Democrat
leaning independents
and Republicans or GOP
leaning independents.
Among her fans of voting age,
the largest group, 39%, are 30 to 49.
46% reported a household
income under $50,000.
And in 2020,
after Swift posted on social media
that people should register to vote.
Nearly 65,000 Americans ages
18 to 29 did so in the first 24 hours.
The next day,
that number grew to more than 102,000,
70% of whom were below the age of 25.
When she posted again this September,
she garnered
another 35,000 registrations.
This is not about a stage in a cornfield.
This is about accessing a treasure
trove of invaluable data.
And that's what keeps the Trump
team up at night.
In an era
when most Americans
are splintered into niche TV viewing.
Consider that last week's
AFC championship
win by the Kansas City
Chiefs with Swift's boyfriend,
Travis Kelce, in the middle of key plays
and the pop superstar
rooting him on United the Country insofar
it was viewed by a record
55 million Americans.
So what might be the value
of a Taylor Swift endorsement?
Joining me now is Craig Garthwaite.
He's professor of strategy
at Northwestern University's
Kellogg School of Management.
He coauthored the study
that is perfect for our purposes.
Can celebrity endorsements
affect political outcomes?
Professor, thank you for being here.
The way that endorsements
are courted by the candidates,
the politicians,
they surely think they matter.
Do they?
I mean, it all depends
on the endorsement.
I think it's hard to say.
They wouldn't matter.
And when you see
so many politicians looking for them,
we looked at
Oprah Winfrey's endorsement
of President Obama during the 2008
primary and found
it had a very meaningful effect
on the share of the vote
he was able to get
and was one of the reasons
why he was able to win the 28 nominee
and then become a two term president.
So Oprah Winfrey circa 2008.
Taylor Swift 2024.
You think that's as close
as an apples to apples
as we're going to get
in terms of the stature that each has?
I mean, I think your comparisons
you talked about before.
They're very apt.
If you think about Oprah.
She had just been
one of the time people of the year.
She's
one of the only people
to be on the time Person of the Year
in the 20th and 21st century.
She shared that with Bill Gates,
Nelson Mandela and John Paul, the second.
Look at Taylor Swift
coming out of being Time's
Person of the Year.
This year,
her tours, the sheer popularity
that she has, her ability
to move people to buy products
by simply wearing them.
She looks a lot like Oprah in a way.
And I think she could have
a very large effect on
enthusiasm in this election.
I'm going to
put on the screen your conclusion
because I want the audience to see it.
I've actually read your analysis.
Bottom line is,
you think
Oprah's endorsed
and delivered a million votes
to Barack Obama.
How did you do it?
Explain the role of magazine.
Yes, we use regional variations,
the popularity of Oprah's magazine
and her book club
to identify
where she was particularly popular
and then use that to estimate her effect
on the vote. There.
It is important to note
a little bit different here
that this is a general election,
not a primary there.
You know,
President Obama and Secretary of State
Clinton were very,
very similar candidates
in terms of their policies.
Here they're very different,
President Biden
and former President Trump.
And so I think this is more
about getting people
enthusiastic about to the polls.
So your points on data,
if she did do events,
Oprah did a bunch of events for Obama.
If you've got Taylor Swift out there,
you know, saying you're the problem,
Donald Trump, that you like that
that's going to change the nature
of why people want to show
up to the polls.
Right.
I mean, you made this clear
that she was very hands on.
She she
Oprah had never been politically active
like this in the past
when she got involved
for then-Senator Barack Obama in 2008.
So it's one thing,
if it's a simple endorsement via a text,
but that's not what Oprah did.
Oprah was out on the campaign trail
appearing in swing states.
Yeah.
And then you get people
to come to those events.
You get people signed up,
you get people enthused.
If if you imagine going to swing states
and you have a joint event
between Taylor Swift and Joe Biden,
people are going to show up
and they're not showing up for president.
Align
who doesn't appear to be drawing
that level of excitement
from young voters.
They're going to show up
to see Taylor Swift,
the way they show up everywhere,
to see Taylor Swift
in campaigns want people
to turn out to these events.
That's why they have them.
And so she could, if she chooses,
be very powerful in this election.
But it needs to go beyond simply saying,
hey, you should
you should go vote for Biden.
We'll be having these kinds of events
the way that we saw
Oprah Winfrey do all throughout the
primary season.
Okay.
So the
nuttiness of all
of this does not interest me.
All the NFL teams
that would have had to have taken a dive
just so the Chiefs could be elevated,
just so Taylor Swift could adore.
That doesn't interest me.
The data, though, does interest me
because as you heard me
lay out with the metrics
as part of your introduction,
with the touch of a finger,
she gets to reach people
in a way
that the campaigns
would be dying to have that influence.
Yeah,
but she is the ability to reach them
and they're actually going to
listen, right?
I mean, I can't tell you
how many talks you probably get
and I get
from various candidates
reaching out to me
that I just never want to see.
I think her fans would be very intrigued
by what she has to say.
So she both has the direct contact
and the fact that they want to listen
to what she has to say.
Quick final thought.
You are a professor of strategy.
You are in the Kellogg School of Business
at Northwestern.
I guess the issue is, does
she want to sell sneakers to Republicans?
I know the famous
Michael Jordan quote, right,
that even Republicans buy shoes.
I don't know.
From a business standpoint,
this would be a good move for her.
You said it's about evenly divided.
It's a very contentious issue.
That said,
I think she's at the point
where she's financially stable enough
that if she wanted to sort of influence
the election on a personal level,
she has the ability to do it.
And I think that, you know,
she has to make a decision about
what is more important
to our being involved politically
or being involved in business.
Right.
There's an expression for that.
It's something you money.
And she certainly possesses it.
Thank you, Professor.
I believe. I mean, I can't.
I can't finish the phrase. Yeah.
Thank you.
I want to know what you think.
Go to my website. It's.
We're kind of stuck.
Okay, now you know why?
This is the poll question today.
Could Taylor Swift determine
the outcome of the presidential race?
What's the number?
Like 40,000 votes in three states
determine swung the last election.
Could she have that kind of influence?
More social media reaction
from the world of YouTube, I believe.
What do we have?
If Taylor Swift makes
that much of an impact
on the American election for 2024,
I feel very sorry for the future. Right.
But Ma, I just explain like 40,000.
I think the literal number
was 44,000
in the last cycle in three states
could have determined
the outcome of the election
in a different way.
Could she have that kind of influence
by registering people in her prime
demo to vote?
It is conceivable. It is conceivable.